uh
two notepads sorry
hey uh just want to let you guys know
sometimes you're asking hey what are you
what is Mud Club well first off it's the
big middle finger two big Tech that's
the most important thing uh but we also
are launching all kinds of new shows and
uh you know Monday is Labor day it's a
poor excuse for picking a business
owner's pocket every first Monday of
September but
we're not going dark uh we'll be
introducing a new series uh this Monday
so you can tune in if you're out there
on the boat or barbecuing uh where Brian
Callan Nick depalo Jim Brewer all in one
room at one time Monday September 4th
here's a quick teaser murderer's row
don't you love it I pulled the Chelsea
Handler but I had you do a bit before
and then I took it and made it mine how
do you know what Chelsea handle does you
watch that
there's been a shift in the landscape of
Comedy first I was told to shut up
because I would never understand then I
was told that silence was violence
[Music]
you wanna call me right wing you want to
call me a conservative I'm a proud
conservative
somebody comes up here and goes you're
Politically Incorrect and I go you don't
read Chomsky do you
[Music]
why am I all of a sudden some right-wing
fanatic but there are certain things I'm
willing to fight for
welcome to murderer's room airing Monday
September 4th 10 a.m Eastern for the
very first time
[Music]
[Applause]
oh glad to be with you that's a Monday
going to be Murderers Row going to be a
lot of fun and we have hilarious a
portion of murderer's row uh here today
look let me give you a rundown maybe we
should start adding a graphic you know
what guys comment below or hit like if
you'd like us to add a graphic of the
breakdown of the show the topics that
we'll be hitting I like it because
sometimes people like I know you say it
but I'm I'm a visual guy
I need visual aids which by the way we
will be talking about the lgbtq
community today
Canada and your membership and it's not
visual HIV I don't care
uh Canada has issued some Travel
warnings for the lgbtq plus Community uh
traveling to the United States it's very
silly and I'll explain to you it's
government propaganda uh Rachel Maddow I
know you usually don't care about him
but uh has uh predicted that Donald
Trump would be a dictatorship who would
never relinquish power so we're going to
get into how former Vice President Joe
Biden actually acts quite a bit more
like a dictator than president Donald
Trump some people say former president
some people say sitting president I say
sitting president okay and then the
Gadsden flag kid that's been making the
rounds yeah this kid this kid deserves I
mean I don't know what you how I don't
know what you give that's age
appropriate but Liquor and fight
like hell shirt yes there we go that's
better as well we'll split the
difference and an old bottle of the wild
turkey no so we're going to be talking
about that in uh more saying here's
something else with the gas and flag we
want to get into are you aware of the
history behind the Gadsden flag
because and you can comment below you'd
only accept their premise that it's
hateful and this child needs to be
reprimanded if you believe that it
represents slavery
spoiler alert
or if you're an idiot I think is a
better way well you cut off my head
shake yeah sorry I can't do the timing
of the head shake if you do the if you
talk
you have my shirt off did you did it
again yeah that's right we are wearing
the same shirt we are not coordinated
because so many people out there are
preparing for Labor Day all right you
hear them you love them ridiculous
it's number two Gerald Morgan CEO how
are you sir I'm doing well how are you
I'm doing fine had a busy morning had a
busy morning I don't know if this is
normal I think I have the smartest uh
smartest children in the world A to Z
the entire ABC's including now I know my
ABC's next time won't you sing with me
barely two by five years old that's
actually that's good yes
two that's pretty good too do you need
some visual aids I do with those coke
bottle glasses Mr banjo because all
right and in third chair when you hear
this
hey did it you know who it is Friday and
Saturday September 1st 2nd he's going to
be at Wise Guys in Salt Lake City Utah
wearing his holy undergarments I didn't
go check out his other dates at
briancallen.com Brian how are you sir
I'm just a man and when it comes to this
music I want a fan in my face and that's
something I'm not going to compromise on
anymore well it's good my hair blown
back the way it looks when I'm riding a
horse a steed a stallion you're an
uncompromising man I appreciate that bro
and I don't understand it I have a
question Brian in Utah do they do they
are these people sober at your comedy
shows what do you mean I don't
understand that question what I'm saying
is can they even they're drunk on God oh
boy come on Mormons are good but there's
a there's a two Seer Stone minimum now
huh tablets
of all of all of my languages that uh
ancient Egyptian uh whatever that's
right all right so before we do that uh
here's a video of a guy who claims that
conservatives are hypocrites for
treading
this is a rite of passage admonish
yourself yeah you do have he's learning
how to operate tricaster because tool
man is always here he never takes a sick
day
and Tool Man by the way he's going look
this has been on the schedule for like
for like six months I have to be honest
I'm like of course oh man that's fine
he's like I just don't I don't have
anyone I don't have anyone who could do
the tricaster I'm like well just show
someone he's like I can't give up
control
so
so we appreciate the Valiant effort
Yakuza but don't go until I finish my
phrase you got it
this guy claims that conservatives are
hypocrites for treading that's the word
of the day on people of color and the
lgbtq piece the government has no right
to take my rights away that's why I fly
this flag that says don't try snatching
your nose ring
um yeah you know I get it I see where
you're coming from uh in that case don't
tread on me yeah yeah don't tread on me
either
the thing is we can still tread on you
you just can't Tread On Us homo yeah I
think that's where the confusion uh lies
ah Down syndrome Charlie Hunnam does the
old reverse psychology
you almost got us there for a second oh
wait so you're saying hold on a second
you're saying that we're treading on you
ah yes oh
that sounds like more of an invite any
hole will do it's just not true at all
we've been over this I I've really
disliked this guy because I didn't read
the setup to this and at first I'm like
oh okay it makes sense and I'm like oh
he's trying to make fun of us yeah he
looks like a stylish Druid yes that's
what I like about him what I didn't know
warlocks were that good looking yes
exactly you know what I mean they're
gonna just show up at Stonehenge and
they're like I did that
why must you have that bull ring in your
nose for my Brew hey because I hate my
father and he hates you back all right
let's play it one more time just I just
want to see if I understand the logic
here and again this is the argument
they'll always they'll try and use right
oh yeah you're for limited government
until it comes to a woman's body well so
the woman has uh the woman has 20
fingers 20 toes no no I'm for limited
you don't believe that I should choose
what car I drive you don't believe that
I should choose what size of size of a
convenience beverage I pick up the
7-Eleven you don't believe that I should
have a choice as it relates to school so
they always say oh you're for Choice
until or they'll say oh well you don't
want to be shredded on until but you
have a problem with these people what
burning down stores what happened to the
First Amendment
oh it's hard hard to argue with that
logic let's go back the government has
no right to take my rights away that's
why I fly this flag that says Don't
Tread on Me Okay
um yeah you know I I get it I see where
you're coming from uh in that case don't
tread on me yeah yeah don't tread on me
either
the thing is we can still tread on you
you just can't Tread On Us
yeah I think that's where the confusion
uh lies okay so I know you had something
there Jill I want to go to you please
comment below and again we're still
trying to check out the algorithm on
YouTube so also hit the like button if
you're watching on YouTube uh usually we
tell you to head on over to rumble but
right now we want to see what's going on
with the likes here's a challenge though
one right
which is being tread upon one in the
lgbtq plus Community what oh Sports no
no it's not a right to compete in any
division you want bathrooms it's not a
right for a heavy weight to compete with
wealth or weights it's not a right for a
biological man to compete with women uh
yeah taking a dump at Target well you
already have that one but that's not
necessarily right they can refuse
service for whatever they want uh uh
children getting well no no second
that's not a right that we're talking
about parental rights you're infringing
upon parental rights they have the right
to determine what medication goes into
their child's body unless you're in
Canada right unless you're in Canada
naming one right can anyone out there
you know what even just play Devil's
Advocate one right that is afforded to
uh heterosexual heteronormative we'll
just go with normal people
that you don't enjoy one
I can list a bunch of special rights
that you do that aren't enjoyed but for
example the ability for many people
depending on the state to go into
whatever Sports division you want for
example to be able to speak without
criticism uh when gross violation of of
uh appropriate laws regarding you know
language with children again freedom of
speech but you don't have the right to
display child pornography or pornography
to children but a lot of people get away
with that from the lgbtqp that's why
people are upset you think that people
being upset that you are behaving poorly
is a violation of your rights
it's amazing how they think that this
kind of logic Works don't let it work
you can also claim you're a woman and
join a sorority and walk around with a
racist boner yes giant I mean by the way
this is a boner but I'm a gal so I got a
girl boner and that's not the same he's
a guy who's 60. yeah that's not
threatening at all that's super safe yes
I'm not kidding I think I'm like within
five or ten pounds it's a girl bonus
yeah how's college going honey yeah I'm
running away from a giant man with a
boner but he's a girl
the chaos
chaos was when he has a boner but was he
having was it that time of month was he
was he having his period at the same
time maybe maybe it was messing with his
head how do you know he's a man well
when a man chases me out of the woman's
locker room with a raging erection and a
butcher's knife I figure he's not in the
old oak I never should have joined
Captain he's not collecting for the red
Crossing for the Red Cross you're about
to say something Gerald oh we have so
much to talk about I was gonna say
exactly I'm not kidding exactly what you
use boners no no you're not boners were
you gonna say six four two sixty I was
gonna say what rights have been taken
away like name one yeah so you
completely stole my thunder and my shirt
yep sorry I apologize by the way it's a
live show Monday through Friday 10 a.m
Eastern because notifications don't work
uh and it's on Rumble anywhere podcasts
exist Apple I always want to say iTunes
Apple Spotify Stitcher uh you can go
there and make sure that it's uploading
properly just bookmark it check in
Monday through Friday 10 a.m actually
Monday sorry yeah 10 a.m on Friday is
only on Mud Club if you're not a member
right all right let's go on to this
story uh it's everywhere right now this
12 year old Colorado Spring student
uh the Gaston flag and again the Gadsden
flag if I miss it's really hard to say
get Den flag but I'll sometimes say
gazed in sometimes I'll say Gadsden but
I know it's gad's din flag you can
admonish me in advance it's a tough one
for me
now otherwise known as otherwise
pronounced America yes right and uh
Gerald actually is going to be giving us
a brief history lesson here today but
you guys are passing notes like it's
okay okay this is mine you're always
passing the notes you're always passing
the notes I'm checking no just so you
know 12 year old Colorado Spring student
okay he was removed from class for
displaying he had this flag right on his
backpack now you've heard the story but
the reason that he was removed from
class because some of you again may be
too close right maybe too close to the
forest that whole thing they go oh I
just because he had the flag just
because she's a liberal no no it's not
because the teacher is a lip though that
too it's because the left now wants you
to believe that this flag and it's
completely incorrect we'll get into the
history represents slavery
do they know what the godson flag is
so there
um the reason that they do not
want the flat reason you do not want the
flag that way is due to its Origins
with slavery and raw
what's your origin story dad never
hugged you enough yes
look at the kid looking like what
try it on me
she's a real expert on Origin stories
yeah it's a big X-Men fan real educated
for an educator she was part of the
weapons program now
worse
okay so the assistant principal let me
make sure I get this right uh Beth
danjuma oh my gosh I'm glad that Nick
apology today
[Laughter]
um I'm refraining uh the the assistant
principal obviously well the mom let me
let me be clear a hero here is the mom
didn't let this assistant principal off
the hook and this is what you need to do
we talk about fighting like hell right
when you send us your your comments in
your chat we've talked about it this
week you need to make your voices heard
for the same reason that we're now
allowed to discuss election interference
on YouTube because we did it Non-Stop
and at a certain point they can't ban us
all YouTube said there are so many
people who have questions about the
elections we're not talking about Amy
Klobuchar Hillary Clinton or Jimmy
Carter uh but we can't just remove all
conservatives they cannot ban all of you
from PTA meetings they cannot ban right
all of you from the public school
district this mom didn't let her off the
hook hats off to her yeah it has nothing
to do with slavery that's like the
Revolutionary report
okay okay
um the Confederate
plan okay
I am here to enforce the policy that was
provided by the district
and definitely you have every right to
not agree with it yeah and I mean we
teach him to always stick up for your
beliefs and I mean you're going over the
revolution this for seventh grade I mean
the founding fathers stood up for what
they believed in can't say father oops
this is unjust
[Music]
yeah we've never seen that uh with every
villain Lackey in a film I was just
doing my job just following orders so am
I
figuratively
true no it's true figuratively
figuratively figuratively that's why I
did the hand I know I saw it by the way
I saw it's double-barreled though got
thick fingers
all right absolutely big Palms small
fingers big Palms yes true We call we
call them long Palm yes I hate you Brian
sorry about it he needs a big handle for
his gun keep going I absolutely love you
no I love you so look parents when we
talked about this yesterday I think
behind a mug club right so we were
talking about Mud Club saying hey if you
have any tips on this you have to go do
the work first though this is that you
should do this is the exact thing that
we want to see yes so if you have
something like this lwc tips at
protonmail.com see if you can bring that
up guys lwc tips at protonmail.com think
about the The Distillery that did the uh
I think Roanoke the drag show you may
not know this absolutely shut down shut
down it's a local it's a local story but
hey there there was enough going on
there that they're done they're not
doing drag shows anymore you can make a
difference and we want to help you we
will go to jail to protect our sources
if you want another exactly but this is
what you have to do you have to go and
start the fight yes right you have to go
and stand up for yourself if you send us
a video or an email or something after
that and you've been stonewalled we will
absolutely jump in that fight with you
but we want to make sure that we are
training people who are going out and
fighting not people who are depending on
others to fight for them that's what
most people do with the federal
government we don't want that right you
have to fight for yourself so educating
yourself as well that that snake in the
don't tread on me has 13 rattles for 13
colonies and a just a very simple Google
search would have shown that district
and that teacher well you had nothing to
do with slavery and I'll tell you
something else I wasn't going to get a
full back tattoo but now I have to do
you yeah okay and it's going to be the
Gadson flag yeah it's Den I was gonna
Gadsden darn it yeah I know I was gonna
get your back tattooed to my back but I
don't have the room
you know what that's just not that's
uncalled for I think it's entirely
called for by the way I hate both of you
now the patches were reviewed okay just
to be clear by the school district uh
and uh the Charter School uh Vanguard
not a great not a great night before
boating yeah but they have a sister
School in Tokyo uh it's Black Rock high
now laughs
the charter school is told to have the
parents remove it and the the assistant
principal also told the Colorado Springs
Gazette Vanguard has zero tolerance on
racial issues and takes these concerns
very seriously like my straight bangs
there's a lot of different circumstances
that our code of conduct handles nicely
when then we decide upon a consequence
we always always try to make our
consequence a learning experience
beneficial for the students which makes
you wonder what the school's reaction
was when they first laid eyes on the
flag to create such a policy
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a difference
name that film line I've seen that three
times and it's still hilarious I have a
question for you do you think the
teacher has a point
uh do you think the flag is actually
associated with slavery this is you know
what's more damaging than a lie
it's a half truth stupidity no a half
truth let me stick that Landing there a
half truth is the most damaging thing
that actually exists as far as the press
out there
It's associated in this case it's
largely a lie but that I can understand
some context if they want to say that at
one point it was adapted okay fine it
was co-opted short but the history of
this flag no it's not meant in any way
to be supportive of slavery
but the half truth is they want to say
well people who are involved you know at
that point in time slaves existed
half truth is what's so dangerous out
there because people feel like they have
the information and then they hold that
opinion steadfast for the rest of their
life despite the fact that they're an
absolute so let's go through the
claims versus the truth here because a
lot of people were saying hey you know
can we maybe kind of dive into this
historically this matters the child is
right that Mom's a hero but that's only
the case if you know the history of the
flag and why that assistant principle is
a dummy and and you already knew that by
the banks by the way here's another
question does anyone any man out there
like straight Banks it's purely a woman
thing no man is like you know I really
like a woman in straight bangs I think
it's like an 80s thing right well Betty
Page has straight bangs yeah I know but
that's a whole thing not everyone is
Betty Page okay guys I'm just a real
ladies in the 50s you know what I'm
saying it's like I look like I look like
bombshell Betty no no no no no you look
like a retiree from Hot Topic
it's just no one likes it I'm sorry it's
a dominatrix thing I think actually if
you're if you if you like to be
dominated if that's the case Yakuza well
great if you want to be an understudy
for billions my plan worked I exposed
Yakuza here is the claim okay the claim
is that this flag is intrinsically tied
to the Confederacy southern slave states
let me just give you some examples of
these headlines all the references are
available at ladder with crowder.com so
you can read them for yourself don't
take my word for it Washington Post the
disgrace Confederate history of the
don't tread on me flag the Gadsden flag
was not the official flag of the
Confederacy as the Alabama Beacon called
it but several newspapers described it
in those terms yeah what you did
it is not a flag of the Confederacy but
we said that once
several of us said that yeah and
just keep in mind I know some of you are
new here when the T when people say oh
Occupy Wall Street was the first no no
the Tea Party existed as soon as Barack
Obama became president and this was the
emblem this was the symbol of the Tea
Party by the way yeah and you know who
rose up during a lot of black
conservative activists Alfonso Rachel a
huge a huge debt of gratitude for my
career I was just a stand-up comic and
actor until he brought me into a place
called PJ TV at that point I believe Tim
Scott came up with some support from the
Tea Party at one point or was active
Michelle Malkin was back in the day uh
Herman Cain so these guys were out there
I guess waving the slave reflex that's
the claim they want you to believe
here's the truth
and Gerald you're a history buff I am a
little bit of a history buff it's
actually tied to several liberties with
the origin in the Revolutionary War I
kind of similarities I did a little bit
of a Joe Biden there yeah so let me just
give you a quick background let's go to
1775. let's we'll go to 70 75 is created
by Colonel Christopher Gadsden of South
Carolina he was a newly created Marine
Corps displayed this on the drums it was
also flown uh by Essa Hopkins the first
Naval commander-in-chief of the United
States Navy right so the rattlesnake it
was kind of used as a symbol for Great
Britain so what was happening is that
Great Britain was sending over prisoners
does it sound like Australia to anybody
else it was basically being used as a
penal colony we passed some laws in the
states that said you couldn't do that
they did that for about I don't know 40
or 50 years they they said okay then
they came back and started shipping
prisoners back over and they were
starting to commit crimes at a really
high rate Sanctuary cities as well this
seems like a very familiar pattern to
history and what they said is hey we
have what do you say you mean
basically just to piss off the colonies
and they said you know what we have a
lot of here rattlesnakes they don't have
those in Great Britain maybe we should
send those over to Great Britain and put
them in the gardens where the Prime
Minister and all the Lords and everybody
else uh walks and they'll learn to kind
of tread lightly in those areas and so
that's where they don't tread on me
thing actually came from so rattlesnakes
began Benjamin Franklin right it began
to symbolize Great Britain and
oppression yep that's what it was it was
basically saying you're taking our civil
liberties from us so in 1751 Franklin
wrote an article suggesting like I said
sending those rattlesnakes to Great
Britain because they were sending
prisoners 1754 I just love that that he
wanted to know you think about how
properly he's basically out there
discovering he's like
we should fight back against taxation
without representation with my old trick
bag of snakes
I've never heard this sound coming out
of a reptile before it's
[Laughter]
what's in this book foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
going on for almost 30 years by the time
Franklin commented on this by the way
they had reinstituted that policy but in
1754 Franklin actually published Join or
Die which was kind of this cartoon
showing a snake depicted kind of pieced
into eight pieces right yeah and they
were saying look we are separate
colonies but we are trying to unite the
colonies to fight a war this was the
French and Indian war that they were
talking about they wanted the colonies
to unite for control over the Ohio river
and so each one of the eight represented
a colony so this all had big specific
meaning in unifying against tyrannical
government yes and unifying the colonies
right so they actually had no idea what
they were talking about now hold on
you're saying they you're now talking
about the school talking about the
schools say school I apologize I do this
often well it's because we've all been
screwed up in the head with pronouns and
stuff I know every time I read an
article about Ezra Miller it says there
and I'm like well is there a brood
oh it's the pronoun no I'm not going
along with it
um the school didn't know what they were
Vanguard the school right not the
corporation trying to destroy your
country yes which is what she was saying
or I mean it says it's a private after a
brief history lesson I said all right
well oh yeah yeah well that's what it
takes sometimes education and by the way
the Colorado governor right uh is it
Jared Polis yeah he's a Democrat oh I
have it in front of me I just look at it
he tweeted support for the flag he said
the Gadsden flag is a proud symbol of
the American Revolution and uh is this
and a iconic did he write that an iconic
did he say an or a a said a gosh you're
coming on Jared and iconic warning to
Britain or any government not to violate
the Liberties of Americans it's a great
teaching moment for a history lesson and
in this case it's a great teaching
moment for dumb teachers and principals
remember I've told you experts are
advisors and this is the challenge with
children going into school right when
they're spending eight nine sometimes
ten hours a day away from their parents
they have to submit to the authority of
these teachers you want your children to
respect authority to some degree of
course but you want your Authority this
is why parental rights are so important
to supersede that unfortunately you
don't have enough time with them so your
children will believe that they're right
in other words unless you had a mom like
this mom who's a hero by the way
um the kid would go through life and oh
I'm sorry I didn't know I I didn't know
that this was a slavery flag I'm I'm
sorry I'll take the punishment and I'll
move on if I didn't have my dad going to
school we have a zero tolerance policy
he said hold on a second my son was
being punched in the face and so he
punched back they said well we have a
zero tolerance policy he said okay son
that's stupid are we done here let's go
get ice cream if I even have a dad and a
mom like that I would have said oh Zero
Tolerance all violence is equivalent
thank you principal I appreciate it this
is why you need to be involved uh you
need to be involved in your children's
lives and it's okay educate the
Educators yeah you know it's also by the
way you were using the expression how
half truth things like this are actually
anti-truths and what I mean by
anti-truths is that they are trying to
erase what's true about history and and
doing it in under because either they're
ignorant or they're ideologues and that
to me is that that's actually more
dangerous yeah but she is unwilling to
do any research exactly so this parents
this is what you're facing yeah I know
and you so you have somebody who comes
in and says hey that's not what this
means somebody who's in a school
I've dealt with it in my environment is
unwilling to do any research which is
exactly what they're trying to teach
kids to do so here's what you can do if
the school came back and said something
about that have him do an effing book
report on what the Gadsden flag is and
submit it to the school district so that
they can be educated on it all they had
to do was go okay uh you're saying it
means something else I didn't know that
this person said slavery I thought
slavery because the only reason sorry I
cut you off you did but that's okay
slavery because I mean I associated with
the Vietnam War I didn't win every
little history of it no now like we
talked about it I'm like I've seen that
flag more with people protesting the
government because they see it also in
Vietnam
right exactly so that I didn't even
think slavery when it came up so I was
like all you have to do is look online
and go oh we have a guest and flight
lighter here somewhere but isn't it a
Texas thing on on your try on your
license plates not in Texas
so now Brian can't be bothered I don't
know nothing I don't know anything how
do you do an accent but because that's
my defense mechanism I become Italian
because my first language is it might be
there might be an option to get one on
the Texas license plate but yeah okay
there might be an option yeah see I told
you Steve but it's not associated
typically with that right look the only
reason that this woman recanted just to
be clear is because there were enough
eyeballs that's why you send in your
tips that's why we highlight these
stories it's more important than the top
marginal tax rate think about this for a
second they want your child to spend
nine hours a day in a place where men
and women male female is a figment of
their imagination
but the Gatson Flag represents slavery
the only reason this teacher or sorry
assistant principal I guess was the one
who laid down the law finally uh the
only reason they changed it was because
there was some kind of visibility and
accountability that's what they fear is
sunlight you don't think the teachers
have the right to abuse their Authority
and they do it for crying out loud I had
a teacher at my centennial Regional High
School he demanded that you call him
doctor I called him Mr may I won't say
his name because he'll probably assume
Mr whatever anyone out there from
Centennial I know that you watch you
remember this guy I didn't call him
doctor by the way he had a doctorate he
had a sorry a PhD in philosophy and I
called him Mister he made me write a 500
word essay on the sex life of a ping
pong ball because he also thought he was
a comedian guy was a dick and the guy
did that just because he could otherwise
I get an after-school detention which I
wore with pride I didn't write that
now this Governor about how the second
ball had a better sex life than the
teacher there's a show in Mexico
sorry guys not here not for this show
this is a family show so this Governor
by the way also later uh compared the
Gadsden flag because he had to appease
him right to the lgbtq plus aaip flag
saying other kids have LGBT Flags what's
aaip what is that
there's uh asexual I don't know what the
other A1 then there's intersex and
pansexual wow because in Canada it's I
think it's a i i p I don't know it
doesn't matter okay other kids have LGBT
flags on their backpacks others have
flags of major political parties or
flags that support whatever causes they
do and that's part of learning from one
another now I understand that and of
course if the kids want to have an lgbtq
flag absolutely now when it comes to
learning I would say uh you know the
historical context of the Revolutionary
War and Benjamin Franklin like you said
attempting to turn this nation into a
penal colony along with introducing an
invasive species so there's an ecology
lesson there is more valuable than
chicks with dicks
uh or guys with tits yeah well let's
move on to Rachel Maddow
oh boy she does look like a guy
and
uh if you if at any point by the way I
don't know if they've already hit this
YouTube we have the YouTube dump button
so we don't self-censor issues
[Music]
that means head on over to rumble let's
see
[Laughter]
uh maybe we should let's send that to
Mom let's send that Mom and the son some
merch and uh yeah somebody can let us
know if they know I don't want a doxy no
I don't want to bring them no then send
it to the tips line and we'll we'll make
sure that we get in touch with them yeah
that's what happened with Stephen
Williford with acetylene Springs
shooting remember his whole family
reached out and this is the first show
that he did oh I'm glad you said that I
have an update for everybody that you're
gonna love and we have to take it's not
just on mug Club I want everybody to be
able to hear this of somebody who had
leukemia about a year ago that reached
out to us we sent a merch kit to them
and everything very happy story so uh I
think we've got somebody in control room
who can send that over so I sent it to
us before we leave before we before we
go to that yeah absolutely and uh you
know what we will rely on you guys to
comment any platform where you are and
tell I remember that person I don't
remember the name I don't either I
remember the story yeah I'm assuming
remission please don't tell don't don't
do like a bait and switch it's a shallow
great was a success that's like no it
doesn't have leukemia it turns out it's
Progeria and a lifespan of 30. that's
not what's happening I wouldn't do that
to you trust me
a cheery
it's an aging disease you guys yeah well
apparently Steven thinks it's funny to
make fun of kids with Advanced the whole
nation did that's how we deal like we
all turned a blind eye to Charlie Brown
come on
nobody else was it Progeria Charlie
Brown and the great Make-a-Wish patch
you're already in it Rachel Maddow
she might have balls your honor
who said that and if you can believe it
Murderers Row on Monday is way worse way
way worse uh so on Tuesday uh MSNBC host
Rachel Maddow uh this uh person
predicted that Trump would declare and I
guess we're going to play the full thing
and pause and play because it's pretty
long but a lot of you saw that not that
many people watch Maddow just to be
clear I mean there are far more of you
and far more of you and mug club uh if
you were to actually compare apples to
apples but this is something that has
been echoed I've seen by a lot of people
on the left right they're they're trying
to scare you into the idea that if
Donald Trump is elected he's going to
you know become a a Putin or going to
become a Kim Jong-il or oon whichever
one you prefer I don't like either uh
here is Rachel Maddow talking about this
from yesterday the election means one of
two things
if this is the way he's going to
approach it either he loses the election
and he goes to prison
or he wins the election he doesn't go to
prison
and is that for life that he gets to be
president will we keep having more
elections okay pause hey there's an
option number three uh let's say he
doesn't win the election and also
doesn't go to prison see the half truth
assuming guilt yeah assuming guilt this
is someone who doesn't believe in due
process right you're innocent until
proven guilty and if the past is any uh
accurate or reliable indicator of the
future they call him Teflon Don for a
reason so her binary Choice that's the
one area where she accepts the binary I
guess also computer coding zero zero one
one zero but it's option number one he
wins and he doesn't go to prison or
option number two he loses and he goes
to prison that's not an assumed fact
you're trying to say the only way he
gets out of being convicted is if he
somehow steals an election that's what
you're trying to imply it's just it's
it's not accurate well and he she's also
assuming that he's going to stay in
power forever why okay so he he was
actually trying to scare you no no but
but he was already he had that
opportunity he was in power he thought
an election was stolen and we did have a
piece
I don't understand where this is if you
listen to what she says if you watch
watch how she finishes this because what
she's equating Trump voters to are
terrorists well let's let's let her and
then let's let's continue watching
stupid cell
if every election is a new opportunity
for him to go to prison do you think he
allows us to have new elections
I mean if those are the states if
winning the election is his place I can
pause hold on a second if the stakes are
every single time someone you don't like
wins the presidency and once they're out
of office you indict them the rules of
change just to be clear this is
unprecedented certainly for the kind of
that's been going on and I
don't know if you know this but what
Barack Obama did to the Donald Trump
campaign makes Watergate look like
Child's Play I'm talking about you know
the analogy here I'm not not the spot
that's terrifying yeah
he killed a teacher with a ruler
continue
what happens in that election if and
when he does not win it
does that kind of an election end with a
graceful concession to a fair and square
re-elected President Biden already has
pause does it end with you spying on
your opponent's campaign as Barack Obama
did let's do a whole segment by the way
and Barack I feel like people gloss over
that it's not a conspiracy Barack Obama
was spying I'm not talking about Russia
collusion just to be clear I'm talking
about Barack Obama they were spying on
the incoming president Donald Trump on
his campaign
Nixon didn't even know what happened
with Watergate it's the fact that
afterwards you try to cover it up for
for political uh for political reasons
because he didn't want to be you know
what Nixon said when he found out about
Watergate being bugged you can listen to
the phone call because he was also silly
enough to record himself because he
thought full transparency I want this
for the historical record I believe it's
exact words and when he's told about
they bugged the water game he goes well
who's the jackass who cleared that
whereas it came directly from Obama so
let's talk about leaving gracefully or
do you mean like the clintons who
literally removed the W's from every
keyboard in the White House when George
W bush came in well that's kind of funny
it is kind of funny but the idea that
it's graceful
all right let's continue
I mean if Trump and his supporters see
the stakes as losing and going to prison
winning and being president and probably
president for life
how should we expect that he and the
Republican party and Republican
officials in swing states are going to
handle the conduct of that election that
Trump may very well lose
and because we are prone to forget we
have to say out loud bideness
that we would be remiss we would be
willfully naive
to ask that question as if our politics
exists in a vacuum
somewhere outside the rest of our news
find your words as if the politics pages
are totally different than the crime
pages right as if we are not in a moment
where far right politics is coinciding
with far-right violence with regular
shows of force from paramilitary extreme
right groups and with acts of violence
by people who are explicitly and
admittedly motivated by far-right
eliminationists hold on a second pause
this really quickly so there you go well
was that the end of it I guess yes yes
okay that's the end well hold on a
second let's go through this will you
talk about and I'm going by wrote here
again you guys kind of see it's like I
don't really have a a prompt or what I
have is a map that tells me which Clips
we're about to run
gone by wrote black lives matter protest
last count we saw was two billion
dollars but that was within the year of
damage damage is done uh thousands of of
uh casualties between officers and
people not to mention how many deaths uh
and entire towns and economies destroyed
right now we know you're saying hold on
a second I don't know if black lives
matter Inc would count as an
organization considering that actual
organization funds which by the way is a
501c3 registered publicly just to be
clear use those funds to buy
multi-million dollar houses I think that
would qualify as an organization let's
combine that with antifa you're looking
at thousands of casualties and that
billions of dollars in Damages name me
one one right-wing paramilitary group
that has inflicted that kind of damage
on the American public and you know what
on the black community itself one your
turn go I'm not gonna not gonna give you
a cheat sheet because I already know the
answer
and this this if you listen to what
she's not saying at the end of that when
you say that what you're really saying
is that hey anybody who votes for Donald
Trump yeah whether they're a republican
official or they're a voter is an
extreme far-right terrorist so what does
that imply what that implies is it would
be it is uh it is prudent and it would
be advisable to actually arrest shoot
and silence all of those people so she's
she is she is calling anyone who
supports anybody she disagrees with in
this case Trump uh a far-right violent
extremist that is what she's saying I
will say this every single member by the
way every when they say oh on a second
there's far right and there's far left
and I'm a Centrist I take it on an issue
by issue basis every single member of
the DNC at a national level every single
one and Rachel Maddow and every single
host at MSNBC is actively involved in
supporting violence as a matter of
policy just with the one correct correct
castrating chemically children or
puberty blockers that's violence yep
you're committing violence against
children you are already more of an
extremist no it is not extreme it is not
an extremist point of view to respond
with I don't want my son I don't want a
teacher to be able to report me to CPS
and take my children away if I don't put
them on puberty blockers oh why is that
are you an extremist because he's six
how about partial birth abortion yep any
one of you want to stand up put a limit
on abortion we're not even getting to
hey how many war crimes has Donald
where's code pink Donald Trump been
drafted up for uh zero yeah yeah we're
talking about violence in that very same
speech here's the funny thing which says
he won't relinquish power let's go back
to January 6th he said March on
Washington make your voices heard
peacefully and patriotically if he's a
dictator you think we'd be having a
debate about whether Mike Pence had the
authority to certify the election it
would be irrelevant because he'd walk
he'd just ride in in a Panzer by the way
Rachel Maddow went on to explain more
about this or try and sort of I guess
reconcile her position with her
inconsistencies but unfortunately she
was kidnapped and used as bait for
Batman so she has she has a full
schedule
she makes a good Robin she does I like
that you used a Panzer that's a that's a
World War II a German World War II uh
tank reference
president Trump's a renaissance man I
did not know Michael Black they used to
this is a half track and by the way
this is uh not the first time that the
left has uh tried to insinuate that
Donald Trump would be a dictator
foreign
[Music]
I love how that actually supposes that
Donald Trump will never age and live
forever and by the way I was assured
that we would not be on this planet
anymore because climate change would
have taken us out far before we would
ever get to 21 anything
this is this is the stupidity of her
argument right now Brian you made a
great Point
how dare you I hate all of you come on
he's talking about my great Point hold
on a second let me set this up first
we're going to compare hold on because I
want you to finish but just so you're
you guys and girls and Z's watching we
are going to compare actual dictator
moments of former Vice President Joe
Biden to Donald Trump but continue
exactly well Brian you had an okay Point
great it's been downgraded it has been
Thanks Steven your point has made
landfall yeah um so basically he is
saying that you're othering somebody and
you're basically saying that they are
the threat to democracy they're going to
steal this country let's look at the
policies that we are actually trying to
get put into place make sure that the
elections are secure we think that
something fishy happened last time we
didn't overthrow them we tried to use
every legal means possible to address
the situation we even did a a fully
peaceful transfer of power even after we
thought that the elections were stolen
and you guys didn't do anything about it
yeah and so now all we're saying I'm
just I'm trying to call it 100 I'm
trying to give them a little bit
absentee ballots all we're saying is hey
for us to have a functioning
Democratic process of electing a
president you have to make sure that the
elections are secure that's all we're
asking for okay but that exactly that is
seen as violent and far right to make
sure well first thing you're asking for
voter ID next thing you're demanding
your citizens Clank pots and pans so
they kill all the sparrows who are
destroying their crops well that's not a
bad idea sometimes the grackles the
architecture the architecture Rachel
Maddow is providing the architecture for
tyranny yes when she says something like
that the next step is if she's saying
that people are trying that will use
violence to keep Donald Trump in for
life so what do you do about that well
you got to get the Army remember the old
philosophy right the exercise we would
have and I know this I took Humanities
101 in college whereas would you go back
in time and kill Baby Hitler well that's
not even an issue now because they're
saying Hitler is there now Donald Trump
yeah Donald Trump is Hitler that's right
don't go back in time and kill Baby
Hitler you're telling people kill
currently existing Hitler but yeah
that's true let's compare this with what
I would argue and you guys can add to
this if you want it's an interactive
experience that's why old media is uh is
dead uh some dictator moments dictator
moment number one from former Vice
President Joe Biden I'm completely
ignoring the Constitution and let me
give you some examples all references
available at lotto.com the rent
moratorium remember that on August in
2021 the Supreme Court ended that CDC
Federal eviction moratorium
but the Supreme Court said no I can't do
that what did Biden do former Vice
President Biden
we just said I'm gonna do it here's a
clip by the time it gets litigated it
will probably give some additional time
while we're getting that 45 billion
dollars out to people who are in fact
behind in the rent now here's the thing
that would still be pretty bad if it was
the end of it but the Supreme Court in
November of that year said uh absolutely
not your extension is completely
unconstitutional they went they made
sure to say no no we really want people
to know that you are violating the
Constitution here he knew it 100 he knew
it he just said it exactly the cdc's
thing expired they said you can't do
this in the federal government Joe Biden
said you know we're going to do it I
know that this is unconstitutional but
right between now and when the court can
actually hear the case we'll give away a
bunch of free money huh yeah how is that
not authoritarian well here's the thing
if it was the only example we had you
know maybe it was senior old demented
circus as long as it's not your money
it's fine yeah it's our money
and I need it now
so a student loan forgiveness very
similar example but this was in uh 2023
I believe so you have June 2023 the
Supreme Court ruled that Biden could not
just unilaterally forgive student loans
and by the way unilaterally forgive
student loans just to be clear that
means take your money and give it to
someone getting a master's in gender
studies just to be clear it's by the way
single biggest government mandated
transfer of wealth that would ever exist
in this country why because the people
who would be receiving these loans are
largely upper middle class white people
we did a whole segment on it you can
just search through our archive so the
Supreme Court said absolutely not you
can't do that and what did former Vice
President Biden say
yeah I can do it
the Biden Administration says more than
800 000 student loan borrowers will have
their remaining federal student loans
forgiven over the next several weeks
today's announcement will impact 39
billion dollars in student debt
according to the Department of Education
this will be automatic forgiveness and
borrowers will be notified it kicks off
the president's new student debt relief
program called Save which will lower
monthly federal debt payments based on
factors like income family size in some
cases reducing monthly payments to zero
yeah just reduce them well no that's not
loan forgiveness it's just reducing your
payments to zero yeah
what I'd love to do that when I go into
it that's wrapping a bad idea in a
pretty package it really is going to
your bank for a mortgage well look we
think we can do this as a percent on
financing yeah okay but let's talk about
the payments how do you feel here at
Chase about
yeah I'm gonna need this I'm gonna need
this that's this loan on the house yeah
yeah I know you're saying you know 2400
I'm a zero guy myself or a zero guy yeah
yeah I want you I want you to take that
check add a bunch of zeros and take off
anything else
free money so here's another
moment from former Vice President Joe
Biden this is a big one uh hey my body
my choice
what about the vaccine mandates you know
what that's giving it too much credit
the MRNA injection experimental yes the
MRNA experimental injection mandates
August 2021 right the military uh
mandated covet vaccine for any of the
service members okay now I know you're
saying military that's government but
hold on a second this really they don't
have the right to tell you what you can
do uh what you can put into your body in
every other facet they can bar you for
example from service or certain if
you're taking drugs
this is not something that's typical to
say you have to take an experimental
mRNA injection it's not the same as a
standard vaccine that's why I don't want
to use the term vaccine so the military
mandated it that in January 19th 2023
the Mandate was rescinded oh because
over 17
000 service members refuse the vaccine
the good news is at that point the
people who stayed with the lgbtq
soldiers or as we call them super
soldiers at the front line there were 83
front the front those at the front hole
8 300 were discharged then in November
2021 the by administrative Biden
Administration mandated a bunch of
coveted regulations any firms with 100
employees
all had to be vaccinated I Believe by
January 1st 2022 was that the policy
January 4th 2022 yep January 4th 2022
the holidays yeah all healthcare workers
at facilities receiving government
payment had to have their workers
vaccinated so now we've gone beyond okay
you work for the government right this
is what people do with freedom of speech
well if freedom of speech just means
that the government can't tell you what
you can and can't do they go well the
Mandate doesn't apply that just means if
you want to work for the government then
they go well it just means it applies if
you want to work for any company that
receives any money from the government
and then it goes well it really only
applies if you work for any company who
receives any kind of tax break that
every single company would need to be
competitive including mom and pop
businesses and that's well look everyone
else has been mandated at this point why
are you special that's how it happened
so all the health care workers at these
facilities right who are receiving any
type of government Aid subsidies uh
relief which of course at that point in
time think a lot of people were because
they had been shut down pretty much
everyone sorry this is this is pretty
much everybody being involved yes and
then you're saying well it's consequent
well thousands of health care workers
quit thousands and thousands and
thousands I wonder how that affected uh
Care by the way I just want to make sure
you understand the timeline here so
August 2021 is 16 months after the
outbreak of the pandemic we knew a heck
of a lot by then uh January 4th 2022 is
almost a year a little bit over a year
and a half a year and eight months after
this and you're telling me that people
still had to be vaccinated even though
we understood that the vaccine by that
time we understood this stuff
foreign
[Music]
did have some yeah they were kind of
yeah like people were told
[Music]
hey from former Vice President Biden
while they're talking about Donald Trump
weaponizing right the government uh this
guy
former Vice President Biden by the way
so did Barack Obama just to be clear
Barack Obama current president
um
weaponized the justice department
against all political rivals right so
let's just go through Trump obviously
the doj filed a bunch of federal charges
against Donald Trump for indictments
right he's facing 91 charges that's what
we're up to now 712 years and the six
months in prison and the theoretic yeah
the six months and the theoretic death
penalty just to be clear it's that
that's kind of existing out there yeah
for treason
I mean I mean Carla Homolka got less
yeah
at the same time again is is the law
treated equally well Hunter Biden was
treated of course with kid gloves this
is a guy who not only evaded taxes this
is a guy who obviously violated Firearms
laws this is a guy who committed I mean
as long of a list of drug felonies as
you can think up and then some that you
wouldn't even imagine you can tack that
on the list anyway not to mention the
kind of money laundering and and deal
that's why of course he was but at least
he gave his four-year-old two of his
original paintings yes yes so you got to
be a little bit fair and he gave his uh
his niece two of his original nude
photographs yes but they're tasteful
nudes he was posing on a log yes exactly
good Shadow unfortunately it was a
Cheese Log so I don't know it's just it
doesn't seem sanitary it's called
cholesterol
um January 6th let's look at the January
6th protesters right yeah prisoners yeah
put in those conditions for think about
this the Q Anon Shaman I know you guys
like to laugh like oh it's silly he
painted his face yeah so does everyone
who goes to or every Super Fan of a
college football team could be clear
yeah the guy said let's be peaceful this
guy was putting this guy was put in
prison for a long time the ACLU said
prolonged solitary confinement as
torture and certainly should not be uses
a punitive tool to intimidate or extract
cooperation that's the ACLU and do you
know who agrees that weaponizing the doj
is bad
Mr Rachel Maddow I don't know what I
expected to hear from outgoing Obama
administration officials but the answer
that I got surprised me the answer that
I got was that the worst case scenario
they could imagine
was that the president the incoming
president that'd be Trump Donald Trump
would use the justice department as a
weapon that that is the single most
dangerous thing that a president could
do to the country on his own say so the
awesome power of Federal Criminal
prosecution and federal criminal
investigation should be seen as
essentially a domestic nuclear bomb from
an ill-intentioned you know what else I
would toss in with the doj or our
intelligence Community let's wrap it all
up into one shitty sack
foreign
[Music]
they raided his apartment and took
everything but the hunter Biden laptop
right which they already had in their
possession at the time another one of
them yes they knew about it son I'd love
for you to comment below think if you
could give me some other examples I know
sometimes we just don't have enough time
in the day we probably won't be able to
get to the CBC story today let's do that
one tomorrow yeah because we want to do
the update with the mug Club member
smash the rumble button it it helps with
the algorithm there on on Rumble of
course it's a live show Monday through
Monday through is um man that was good
Jill what the what are you doing I'm
sorry man I didn't eat breakfast but I
just needed a quick bite of pudding I
was getting kind of hungry pudding it's
going it's going later here yeah yeah
you're eating you're eating pudding yeah
it's the pudding from my Patriot Supply
you're eating the pudding from the three
months yeah bucket of the my Patriot
Supply wow wow my God this is so good I
know right please don't tell me that it
is pudding as well Brian I'm sorry it's
just very good it's very creamy just
don't eat the pudding okay guys you're
always eating I don't care if you dip
into broccoli cheddar soup
yeah solve that is through pudding yeah
grind yes this is why this is why I have
like four three month emergency food
buckets back there from Patriot Supply
none of which have put it yeah but you
can just get more because Patriots play
is doing a 200 free delivery for the
three-month kid well that doesn't help
me if I keep ordering them and I don't
have any pudding see the problem is that
the rate limiting factor here is not the
kits which are great kits don't get me
wrong so wait you you want me to eat
only the pudding no I want you to stop
eating not the pudding no no see I
thought you no no he's yeah he's right I
thought you wanted us to just eat only
the pudding yeah that's what I thought
only the put why would I want you to
only eat I don't know that I thought I
was it was weird and that's what I'm
saying yeah I think we thought too God
it feels good in my mouth
putting on your you don't even need
teeth you don't even need teeth for this
yeah no sorry sorry matter with you guys
so chocolate stop eating fine we'll deal
with the pudding later all right three
month food kit from Patriot supplies 200
off with free delivery you can head over
to uh prep oh I don't have a logo here
prep with crowded
um they have the balls to sponsor them I
think it's the first sponsor on the show
here in months yeah yeah we don't do a
whole lot because it's usually viewers
like you but uh get your your food kit
emergency food kit Patriot Supply and by
the way Patriot Supply if you're
watching can you send me a kit with just
the just the pudding wrapped in a spiked
chastity belt so that I can keep it away
from these absolute animals it's
delicious yeah I think this should
improve your communication skills
because you're not very good at this it
goes down too smooth yeah I know you
gave me I know you gave me the book yeah
but you got to read you go to prep with
kreider.com I can read can you read the
label that says pudding yeah I can read
this and just to be clear by the way
well you guys are out there you don't
hey you used to think you needed to be a
crazy prepper have you had to deal with
an earthquake think of what's going on
in Hawaii right now a lot of people
don't have access to food I live through
the ice storms everyone should have at
least three months of food dried food
some water and some way to heat the food
I also recommend stocking up on
Everclear you can use it as fuel you can
use it as a disinfectant or you can use
it to trade with the drugs that's right
well we're rotting drugs or a hurricane
rotting trunks hurricane in Florida
right now yep so people think people
think that uh you know if a disaster
hits that somebody's gonna land a
helicopter in your backyard it's not
true let me come get you you got to be
ready yeah especially if you're waiting
on Kobe what's the story you were
telling me keep eating oh so I need two
sticks and I can I can make fire all
right so let's go to a moving store I
guess no you should get an update I know
I have an update so we had one of our
people go ahead and bring up the uh the
the I guess the comment or tweet or not
tweet it was it was somebody in Mud Club
I believe that put it back we'll issue
the LG uh well sorry we'll address the
issue of the LGBT travel warning uh for
Canada to the United States tomorrow
because it is funny and there's a lot
going on there it's entirely
government-funded news but uh we just
don't have time today right so mug club
we want to thank you guys for support
like this right so this this is a praise
report coming my son is officially in
remission from the leukemia praise God
he's walking again that is fantastic
thank you all for the prayers and advice
Stephen and the crew you gave me a year
ago I took it to heart and now we're in
a better place thought I'd give you some
good news in these dark Times mug Club
fan for life that's from Mac 5745 so it
might be a second screen to that or
something like that but he got merch
from us we sent him a merch kit like
because the sun you know liked the show
and it was just a dark time for them I
remember this story yeah because that
cures cancer no exactly right it was
just it was a small thing we do what we
can yeah
but I'm really excited about that I
really am because it you know we care
about people like we can't we can't cure
cancer like you said right but when
somebody's going through a tough time
sometimes just a little Ray of Joy or
hope or something yeah is what can get
you through maybe just that day
for allowing us no do that okay I'm just
saying mutagenic cells they feed on
sugar I know but I forget everything I
heard huberman say it once I know but
true I forget about all the bad stuff
but did you say we have another screen
grab from it or no I thought we would
but we don't I think it's just basically
saying that he got a bunch of merchants
I mean thank you for sending us that we
really do appreciate and you know what
hey you know let's talk about the Canada
the LG we'll talk about it on mug club
uh in just a moment here we can do that
yeah we still have time to do that
um I will say this once I when I retire
I am going to be a shopping mall Santa
there's nothing that I enjoyed more
throughout the year yeah than doing the
uh I just want to say no no no no no
let's come on stay in your lane no no
when we get to we always get to pick
Charities you know and and this year we
got to really uh bless a lot of people
but also just sitting there and yeah you
just get to enter you get to actually
improve someone's life with a kid listen
the kids just want to be listened to a
lot of the time it's one of those things
I really enjoy it I will do it I think
when I retire I will be a full-time
Santa if that's a shopping mall Santa
you know if it's a cat burglar the point
is if I don't have to wear the suit um I
cannot wait to sit on your lap
let me let me say this and and Brian
count where are you going to be I'm glad
you asked I'll be it Wise Guys uh Salt
Lake City and then September 23rd I'm at
the Genesee Theater in Melbourne Florida
I'm saying Utah has alcohol before we go
to um uh just want to take a minute to
actually kind of it brings up a thought
you know
I'll tell you this too it's also a
little bit selfish I'm someone I've
discussed this someone who struggled
with you know depression um talked about
this quite a bit
on the show and if you struggle with
that or if you're in a funk uh the best
thing you can do is well two things
first off is is be grateful for things
that you have list them out of gratitude
and esteem others first and Gerald knows
this I'm one of those people who I'm
very grateful but sometimes happiness is
difficult for me to come by and it's
because I'm being ushered from thing the
next thing that day where uh it's not
something and this is a genetic
component by the way they've been
studies in this some people are just
have a more natural proclivity toward
being happy and I don't mean being
friendly or polite there's never an
excuse for not being polite but I'm
talking about joy to being joyous and
for me as someone who struggled with
that I do find that living vicariously
through other people meaning getting to
bring joy to others is really the way
that I experience Joy the most and
that's why you've heard me talk about
this for years I love doing the the
Santa Claus thing just because you get
to experience it you get to it's not a
big deal a Nerf gun right to you but
that's that kid's world and so even if
I'm an extreme example and maybe you're
a naturally happy person but you're
going through a rough spell
that's not a bad idea to try and
experience Joy vicariously through
someone else if right now you're saying
hey it's tough for me to come by I can't
get out of this funk I just can't find a
way to put myself in a good mood see if
there's a way that you can make someone
else experience joy and see if that
actually brings you some happiness I get
it's a little bit selfish but they'll
get to benefit from that too and then if
you make that a way of life it really
does change your outlook and so I really
am glad that this person is doing better
and I will also yep be full transparency
selfishly that's a little dopamine hit
for me that I don't often get through
through you know just living that
through natural methods I mean I get it
absolutely when I just do a boatload of
fentanyl
um
I don't know if it works in this the
next time you have a craving for
fentanyl just look in my face I'll give
you that should be your screensaver
because that's doing it wrong well that
that my my face produces endorphins I
thought you were going to say it's sort
of like the harm reduction shade like
the next time you want to boatload of
fentanyl just take Vicodin
the methadone I step back like instead
of eating a pint of ice cream you know
eat a Popsicle and then you move to like
a Fuji apple I just never find myself
getting there
they are the sweetest in the Apple
family no that would be honey Christmas
you guys can comment your favorite Apple
I like apples it's like God's candy
because you don't need to you don't need
to you don't have to worry about it
being bad if it's bad you know it with a
raspberry you're too far gone and it
just ruins your whole day all right
we're going to continue discussing right
now Canada just issued a travel warning
for lgbtq Plus members this will be if
you're watching on Rumble hit that
button you get to join mug Club 69 sorry
89 annually and you get this show
another full hour of show a Friday show
Alex Jones on Friday Nick depaolo every
Monday through Thursday 5 p.m we're
going to be bringing on new shows here
in the next month Brian Callan boom
Hodge twins of course we have Mr guns
and gears a consultant we have the
investigative unit and you get this hand
etched mug you're a part of something
it's the biggest screw you that exists
at Big Tech we thank you and I live
vicariously through you because everyone
serves a master and I'd much rather it
be you than corporate front hole
overlords thank you Rumble YouTube piss
off
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign